there's nothing cooler than being sneaky
whether you're going full super spy and
sneaking around your opponents hitting
the enemy team with an insane ninja
defuse or stealthily knifing someone in
the back sneaky plays always feel sick
that's why today we wanted to count down
the sneakiest plays we've ever seen now
long time to score esports fans might
remember a list like this from a few
years ago but we needed to update it
with some incredible new plays that
deserve the recognition before i get
into that though i gotta remind you as
always to hit the like and subscribe
button as well as to ring that
notification bell and if you're done
let's count down the top 10 sneakiest
esports plays
kicking off our list at number 10 is
this absolutely insane sneaky fake from
shakesella this is brilliant he's got
all the way past he's trying to find a
double here in the group stage of
dreamhack open 44 triumphs shakezala
decided to sell a fake in the sneakiest
way possible by crouch-walking along
dust2's a site to make his wrap on the
opera completely invisible it was only a
pixel because a lot easier to spot when
you do have the x-ray but he's slowly
making his way around the side look at
his eyes as well you can see he's trying
to spot stuff out the corner
i love the player guys it gives us so
much more information about what he's
doing but this is brilliant he's got all
the way past he's trying to find a
double here rcs about to walk into his
crosshair or walk straight into him in
fact
imagine being that opera you're watching
a plot and this guy pops out of
literally nowhere to kill you brutal
nothing personal kid
coming in at number nine is gamut's
gnats who snuck up on not one not two
but three g2 players during a
semi-finals match at vct masters berlin
how no no but no but how how how is he
there how how is he there i don't
understand how does he manage to do that
and oh he's gonna get a killer pixels
what is this man doing
that is one of the most ridiculous
things i've ever seen this guy
he's defining the word flank
behind them it's
absolutely obscene
oh g2 my heart goes out you are playing
gamut's game at this point he's even
come on yeah he's come up behind for the
third kill he's coming behind for the
third kill
there's a reason they call nats the rat
king he is the sneak attack expert
always skulking around the map where his
enemies least expect him some might call
it lane but gambit took first place at
violet masters berlin last year so nat's
supposed to be doing something right
taking the number eight spot on our list
is stewie2k's sneaky knife on the goat
don't you absolutely
2021 with the bomb already down and the
round basically locked up for team
liquid stewie decided to have a little
fun he snuck up behind simple and went
for a cheeky knife just that early mid
pressure with molotov's going in keeps
navi attentive to middle long enough the
liquid can run and be the barrel
oh no
simple doesn't know this stewie's
sneaking up behind and you can't really
play for a knife here oh you are kidding
me stewie stewie you absolutely don't do
it to him oh insult
oh no sasha gets slashed look stewie is
one of the best cs go players of all
time and he's got plenty more incredible
mechanical plays but getting a stealthy
jump on simple must have felt damn good
coming in at number seven is a devious
flank from the dallas fuels taimou from
fighting in the trenches in the tank war
oh
here we go
[Applause]
during a match between dallas and boston
uprising back in season one of the
overwatch league taimou's reapers
slipped around boston and hit them with
a huge death blossom to pick up a 3k
yeah they have a ton of old stuff boston
is going to have to make this grab
dragon strike combo work the change over
to calios was to give more protection
and get a charge zarya
from fighting in the trenches in the
tank war oh
here we go
[Applause]
gets enough he gets three
whoa we're gonna have to change his name
to slymu
nobody saw that one coming
taking the number six spot on our list
is our first dota 2 play courtesy of ad
fitness and their 200 iq sneaky back
door at the boston majority
[Applause]
after barely holding on to their throne
after a vicious team fight og thought
they were safe four members of ad
finance were dead and maybe next time
looked like he was going to live up to
his name and wait for his team to come
back up for the next push instead of
licking his wound he saw an opening and
shadowbladed into the trees blinked back
into og's base and smacked their throne
with back to back enchant totemed up
auto attacks to blow everyone's minds
corn ambulance call an ambulance but not
for me
they could technically just smoke up and
finish it off
i don't think maybe the next time goes
for that there is just way too much
armor on that engine 15 armor
[Applause]
our fifth entry is one of the many
crafty plays by the sneaky beaky master
himself
snacks who has the op is staring at
upper snack's gonna go right by him
because he's in behind that wall he
lines up too snacks might not be on top
of the world these days but this pgl
season 1 play should remind you that in
his prime the polish star could
literally get away with murder on the
server we've seen him excuse me make
that play work before that nade doesn't
go far enough to catch the eight hp from
seas
that still gives navi the man advantage
snax is now going to take over the
duties of taz and try and get close on
that lower ramp in fact he's gonna push
through it and guardian
who has the op is staring at upper
snack's gonna go right by him because
he's in behind that wall he lines up two
snacks
oh my goodness he's managed to make it
work and guardian doesn't even hit him
how does he get away from a guy like
guardian in that situation
taking the number four spot on our list
is sabrosa's sneaky pistol round ace on
ascent njc standing what a spot here oh
this is gonna be huge
he's gonna spot all of them right now
one two three
looking for the ace right now and it's
about to be peaked out here
silva arrow to come out and he's gonna
win this fight and he does with another
head shot that is what
seven bullets used back in the early
months of valerian's competitive scene
at the clg blitz cup sabrosa found an
incredible angle on all of the mortals
players and dropped four before popping
out to complete the ace
and that's how you start this off
[Laughter]
oh my god this is thick
that was beautiful
wow beautiful so
the play was so iconic that that spot on
ascent is just called sabrosa now
coming in at number three is arguably
esports most legendary backdoor the
xpeke
all the way back at iem katowice 2013 sk
gaming almost wiped fnatic in a team
fight at their base and the game looked
to be over but with his back against the
wall fnatic's ex peke did the only thing
he could he snuck back into sk's base
and single-handedly took down the nexus
while they were distracted you can see
there's coming in that package
definitely up towards the nexus kevin is
going to be
he's trying to do it but meanwhile we're
in the base jenna starts trying to
defend him in the face becky's trying to
take the nexus down is anyone gonna have
to deal with this one catches him with
another x he's very low
this play has gone down as one of the
most iconic plays in esports history in
case you wanted to know why some boomers
still shout x-pak a when they see a
backdoor play
our runner-up play is an absolutely
iconic ninja diffuse from zip x
as the bomb will reach its logical
conclusion is he gonna go for this are
they still down there
oh my god
oh my god back at iem chicago zip was
trapped in a 1v5 situation with no time
left to kill his opponents on north he
had to defuse the bomb but the way he
did was truly extraordinary he robbed
all the way around the map to shake his
pursuers and defuse the bomb to win the
round and the map
classic as zipix tries to work back
inside of the lobby 25 hp only to work
with
as the bomb will reach it's logical
conclusion is he gonna go for this are
they still down there
oh my god oh my god oh my gosh clutch
ministers got a new sermon unbelievable
unbelievable
he is the clutch master
and finally taking our number one spot
is an unprecedented sneaky play that
will go down in league of legends
history demons world's finals baron
sneak no flash no possible engage with
that one now available four barrels wait
wait wait the two man baron is going on
right now edg have no idea
yeah and uh donald kid can throw down
the ultimate from the ziggs the barons
still going down
this is the world finals and they're
sneaking with two people 3k left canyon
going down burning
maker can he actually get awarded to
this bit he does and he gets the bad
news it is taken by khan there was no
smite because he had to use it to stay
alive with edg pressuring them in the
mid lane most people expected damwan to
go back up to their base and reset
instead condon canyon quietly crept up
the river to attempt a two-man baron
while their teammates kept edg busy as
far as we know no one has ever snuck
baron at worlds let alone game 5 of the
world championship grand finals
absolutely brilliant from darwin the
bait and switch was real while edg were
focused on securing that mid tower they
didn't even realize that the baron was
being snuck right from underneath their
noses now with the baron buff they're
going to leverage this to try and get
mid control and look to fight for the
ocean soul while damon might have lost
the game their sneaky play will forever
be remembered
alright folks that's our list if you
think we missed a sneaky biggie play let
us know down in the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
one enemy remaining flawlessly